so hi Steve here again Steve Kaufman I'm
in the interior British Columbia in
Osoyoos playing golf with friends a
lovely part of British Columbia I was on
the internet and someone talked about
the phonetic the international phonetic
alphabet and the need for some set of
symbols that would you know accurately
represent sounds in a language because
as we know especially in English the
alphabet doesn't really represent the
sounds very accurately because it you
know the letter O can be pronounced Oh
or a or whatever depending on whether
it's women or come or over so however I
don't think the international phonetic
alphabet is all that useful
I have never bothered to learn the
symbols of the IPA because to me I have
to first hear the language I have to
hear it accurately and as a non-native
speaker is often difficult to hear it's
difficult to hear where one word ends
and the next word begins and so forth so
one of the really useful tools that we
have today to teach ourselves to hear
the language accurately so that we can
then pronounce it is text-to-speech so
one of the things that I do which
unfortunately I can't do for Ukrainian
because there is no text-to-speech or
Google text-to-speech for Ukrainian
which is very unfortunate but it works
for Polish and for Russian extremely
well
and that is that I save phrases at link
and those phrases then I review them in
the dictation function we have and so I
hear the text to speech sounds and I
have to write it down and it's amazing
how much I miss because I don't
accurately hear what the native speaker
in this case that text-to-speech is
saying so it's a very good way to train
yourself to hear what the person is
actually saying so that's one thing that
I can do with text-to-speech now the
thing I've started doing with
text-to-speech but again only in Polish
or Russian where text-to-speech is
available is that I will have saved
these phrases in
text link and then I review them in
flashcards and we also have
text-to-speech in the flashcard so I
start up an audio of recording so I will
press the text-to-speech on here the
text-to-speech then I repeat it in my
own pronunciation then I go to the next
flashcard and do the same for the next
phrase and so forth and so on and pretty
soon I have a sound file of two minutes
long or so which consists of the
text-to-speech pronunciation of the
phrase and then my own pronunciation I
then listen to that sound file while
reviewing my flashcards and all of this
is helping me to notice what actually is
being said and I think a big part of
pronunciation is actually accurately
hearing what is said I mean we know for
example that often Japanese speakers
have trouble distinguishing between l
and r when they speak but they make the
same mistake when they write and that
suggests to me that they're not hearing
the L and the R when they listen to the
language so we have to train our ability
to hear there are even other ways in
which you can use text-to-speech to help
your pronunciation but I won't go in
though into those today but we are going
to be experimenting with some of those
with our the members of our you know
link Academy live and you should be
following their activities and I'll
leave a link to the videos about their
activities we're going to be working
with them on their pronunciation using
text-to-speech but we won't be using the
international phonetic alphabet
however for those people who find that
useful by all means the main thing in
language learning is to do what you like
to do and what you find useful so and
now I'm going out to play golf thank you
for listening
you